this extra video was made possible by
set app one low price for over a hundred
great Mac apps okay so you're scrolling
through reddit because what else does
one do during the tired hours of 9:00
a.m. to 5:00 p.m. just minding your own
business when you click on a link and
this happens nothing is more frustrating
than a paywall being told that you have
to buy an entire subscription to read
this one article sometimes they wait
until you're halfway through oh want to
know what Snape does next that'll be ten
dollars
well this one's free Snape kills
Dumbledore don't say this channel isn't
a good value but when I think about it
for half a second of course they ask for
money writing and editing and publishing
require labor you know the thing you're
supposed to be doing right now but
instead opened this video and if there
wasn't a paywall I'd be complaining
about how many ads there were the same
goes for music videos apps and so on
long ago deep water navigation freed
merchants from making only what their
town wanted to buy now they had access
to the world's markets as long as
someone somewhere wanted their custom
engraved potatoes they could sell them
today you can specialize even further
make a living say selling homemade
glitter that's pretty cool but when
there are no barriers to entry supply is
unlimited and the value of everything
trends to zero so here we are nobody
wants to pay for music or news or apps
and yet musicians and writers and
developers need to get paid the question
is how preferably in a way that doesn't
suck
Spotify Netflix the New York Times and
the App Store are all attempts to answer
that question
some of which are thriving others you
might be surprised to learn are failing
so what works and maybe more importantly
what doesn't
the iTunes music store opened in 2003
the App Store in 2008 in other words the
music industry has a head start this
graph of music revenue over time
adjusted for inflation tells the story
pretty well earnings peaked in 1999 and
they've been down ever since like really
really down now I'd argue this period
was somewhat artificially high if we
zoom out a little it looks more like an
anomaly a 10 year spike in the long
history of recorded music people spent
so much because they had to their
choices were by music a whole album at a
time or don't listen at all but then the
numbers just start falling if we break
it down by format first LPS EPS and 8
tracks then cassettes CDs and later
digital you can see this time is
different
nothing replaces the CD at least not
immediately you'd think people just
stopped listening busy wondering why the
world didn't end or something but really
of course they just stopped paying in
favor of sites like Napster iTunes tried
to fight piracy by breaking up the album
but nothing really changed until a
Swedish programmer no the other one
realized something the problem with the
music industry is piracy but you can't
beat technology technology always wins
but what if you could make a better
product than piracy it took a few
minutes to download a song it was kind
of cumbersome you had to worry about
viruses it's not like people want to be
pirates
they just want a great experience and
that's how Spotify was born the lesson
is companies can fight change lobby for
new laws burden everyone with annoying
restrictions even more annoying ads and
sooo twelve-year-old girls for sharing
songs or they can adapt see it as an
opportunity because most of us are lazy
if we can pay a little more for a lot
more convenience we usually will
that's why streaming wins today people
listen to more music than ever before an
average of 32 hours a week
that's a lot and revenue is actually
growing for the first time since the 90s
now Netflix seems to be in the same
position both are $10 all-you-can-eat
streaming subscriptions an answer to
piracy and in this case blockbuster
making a killing on late fees before
Netflix the idea of letting users watch
any movie from any device at any time
was ridiculous what if people share
their password Netflix was like ah good
point we should make that easier
they don't just accept it they embrace
it letting you make separate profiles on
the same account but then you look at
money and suddenly the two companies
couldn't be more different one has been
profitable for 15 years making half a
billion dollars last year alone the
other reported almost the same number a
year earlier except its number was
negative why is that in a word
scalability Spotify only takes a small
cut of your $10 a month the rest is
distributed among the songs you listen
to in other words no matter how many
people sign up the economics never
improve more users more costs Netflix on
the other hand licenses shows for a set
period of time seven or ten ninety-nine
a month isn't a lot of money but after
they've paid for content every
additional user is pure profit more
users more money so why doesn't Spotify
just raise prices
well competition every company and their
mother sells a music service just pick
your favorite color
there's also plenty of video sites
Netflix prime Hulu Showtime HBO soon
even more the difference is customers
can and do pay for several at a time
music is winner-take-all we expect every
song to be available on every service
they just aren't unique they also can't
really take a bigger cut because artists
barely survive as it is when Taylor
Swift complains about money you can only
imagine what it's like for the average
musician for many streaming is really
just an ad for their concerts where they
make almost all their money
the
problem is musicians share their revenue
with producers writers and record labels
just three of which Sony Universal and
Warner control most of the industry
Spotify for example pays between six and
eight tenths of a penny per stream but
after everyone takes their cut
artists are left with just over an
estimated one tenth of a penny so here's
my prediction sites like Netflix will
focus almost entirely on exclusives the
stranger things and the West world's
that make their service a unique there
won't just be one winner but several for
music the future may not be so bright
unless something drastic changes like
cutting out the labels services will
land in one of two categories those
owned by a bigger company like Apple or
Google who use them as a loss leader not
to make profit directly but to sell more
phones and everyone else left with no
way to make money this is already
starting to happen it's just not obvious
unless you're looking a movie pass user
can feel the business model fail
underneath them unlimited movies turns
into most movies turns into some movies
turns into only black comedy westerns
starring Adam Sandler only between the
hours of 4:00 and 5:00 a.m. in select
Wyoming theaters but a Spotify user can
just keep happily listening away for now
every song ever written for less than
the price of a single album works only
because investors pay for it but that
won't last forever the industry may look
healthy in aggregate but it's mostly the
top 1% inflating the average it's not
that I don't think developers or
musicians or journalists will survive I
worry which ones survive there are three
kinds of companies those that make money
honestly
those that make money dishonestly and
those that don't when nobody pays for
music or software independent musicians
and developers lose but there are still
ways to make money they just aren't good
ones
journalism won't die but the good kind
very well could some would say largely
has if you think there's a problem with
freemium apps and
in-app purchases today just wait until
that's the only thing that works the
good news is that these industries have
an advantage they don't have record
labels and Spotify offers them a few
free lessons first people will pay for
content but it's on the company to make
it cheap and convenient to adapt not to
fight
second services have to be unique and
finally for it to be sustainable it
can't just be good for you and me it has
to work for the musician the writer the
developer the companies that apply these
lessons will determine which industries
thrive and which just survive today's
sponsor set app is a response to the app
side of this problem it's a $10 a month
subscription to over a hundred and
twenty of the best Mac apps it's good
for you because it's a great value
use as many apps as you want no ads or
in app purchases and every update to
every app is included for free again
full disclosure this is a sponsor but
what they can't pay me to say is I've
been using set app since February long
before they reached out I use Ulysses to
write these scripts CleanMyMac to manage
storage and timing to track my time new
apps are added all the time it's this
quick to install and try one out
I'm not speeding this up and importantly
it's good for developers because they
get an extra predictable and fair stream
of revenue they're incentivized to make
great apps not charge you for an upgrade
every year I especially recommend that
app if you're a student or do creative
work they have some of the best apps for
studying writing photography and
programming if you use a Mac there's no
reason not to go to set app calm and try
it free for seven days
thanks to set app for making this extra
video possible and to you for listening